the LCQ continues you guys have already
seen a few matches we've talked about a
few of them we talked about a lot of the
players but here we are we got more LCQ
action for you guys what's next man look
it I feel like anything could happen
I feel like anything could happen with
the level of players here some of the
potential matchups that can happen you
get stuff like this town o'connor
vs doge aim and you were just saying
don't believe at fighting - yeah I
believe this was at a fighting Tuesday
Joe Joe event that we ran in fall I want
to say this was a matchup I these two
definitely played each other in looser
side I want to say okay you got the back
turn back - not Alayne
who knows I could see the back turn Lars
combo since Tekken 6 usually when the
back turn somehow Lars in the point
underneath them and then making that
making it straight again okay glass oh
man just a little bit I'm great
awareness still has the wall positioning
for him like it's the perfect range it's
like a fullback - almost there again
yeah I mean doujins movement and we're
punishing have been so on point today
specifically with punishing - yeah and
you know I'm actually kind of surprised
we haven't seen the Shaheed I wonder if
he's gonna rock Lars the entire
tournament
I feel like he'll matchup it like it I
think is one of the things that happens
like if he fights certain matchups he'll
switch to Shaheen O'Connor though she
can go Tamil Kannada she has had some
amazing matches dude I'm telling you
right now I feel I feel like she she
gets kind of a raw deal sometimes right
like oh yeah kind of painted as I think
it's a Miss pain right as a mascot or
something like but in certain events I
mean remember ebo strong I mean strong
stop Japan qualify right she yeah she
basically carried her she carried her
team yeah and even the Korea masters
earlier this year had a really good
performance right yeah no I think it's
one of those things with tunnel Kaunas
like she fights certain like players and
then that's when people are like oh man
what about this town O'Conner people
talk about it but like we all know the
Tom O'Connell is ridiculous
right she's just like it feels like
she's just had one big good performance
away from him from being a much bigger
deal right we've said this about like
multiple players like throughout the
years right we said that about John King
and he had that pop he had an amazing
year like right afternoon I feel like
Tom O'Connor is right there as well
always still been super good just
waiting for that big but yeah like you
said yeah this game is one of those
games worth it because there's so many
legacy players and then there's some
also somebody really strong with new
players too it feels like there's a lot
of players who have like really buff
resumes right yeah but they lack that
one big impact win right even Chanel
like it's like that to a degree right oh
my yeah I mean you know honestly last
year the player for me that was that
person last year the entire year was
ranked you yo yeah every single
tournament was like oh he was in top
eight every time it was like fifth place
fourth place
you know fifth fourth fourth and then he
wins the one right at the end when it
really mattered and to your credit Ricky
I feel like that's a player who looking
at tomorrow I feel like nobody's even
talking he's gonna be the back-to-back
to have no one saw it coming twice yes
why he changed his hair he's walking
around to make the top eight into me
especially with a weight that he
wouldn't last year too right you could
tell maybe he caught some people
off-guard there was a little bit of
unfamiliarity but even it's kind of hard
to excuse I mean it's a legacy character
to one's right it goes right back to
those things like there's so many
characters that people play in Tekken
that have been there so when we get
these characters that return and then
people like man nobody knows about this
character and they putting like how's
this guy so good with them you know oh
god it's so pretty yeah shoutouts to
pure arts limited Lucas design this
trophy is amazing that cause via glove
right there gorgeous yeah with the hat
you fist on the other side or IP you
know I'm saying oh no he didn't die
definitely they said he died in Tekken 5
intro bro look closely at the Tekken 5
intro that's why I know you guys are not
real nerds man you see hey Hachi fly
away you see I remember I seen it and
then the tech scammer said hey Hachi
Mishima is dead but that was probably
you is obviously a bad dude
she did not know that about this in
Tekken 7 spoilers man were you trying to
hear that he got bit by a rattlesnake so
coming up next you got cuddle core going
up against yamasa
you brought to you of course by a team
equinox the big thing in she was one of
the high-impact performers from last
year's LCQ - oh really really deep
running now see you next generation
taking players cuddle core is right
there at the 4th she's definitely one of
those people you jus you always are
gonna look at me like for the last like
three years of this oh yeah in your mind
you think of her as next gen I think
she's courage in the mean yeah I think
he means like next superstar yeah yeah
like that's what I mean because there's
it it goes back to a lot of legacy
players right there's a lot of people
who come in to taken in they're like man
cuddle core is good and I feel like when
you compare it to those other older
players her resume is just getting
started she and she's right there on the
cusp of doing the exact same thing I'm
good compared to like what we talked
about with Cooke Omar last year she's in
that sort of position right now where
you haven't seen her have that breakout
horse where she wins right like even we
would go back to that elite tournament
that happened she beat acting like
multiple time I was about them I was
about to bring the numbers like as seen
on tv s the superstation this whole
table y'all alright okay mark was there
too part of the drama with that too
right was like you know there was a
sense of maybe like that was the weakest
team with one of the strongest players
and there was no Jimmy there and Jim and
mr. Nash was expected to carry but then
she stepped up in several on several
occasions during that event team in the
game right yeah Blackwell rips it like
be anakin multiple times anakin
potentially the strongest player in the
united states at this point and why
the world look how well he's been doing
and you still have Coco did that earlier
this year and that's what I'm kind of
like I'm gonna getting it right though
those kind of things happens a lot and I
feel like Tekken is one of the games
where it happens so organically that you
can go back and be like remember when
this happened remember this happened and
now look what just happened the same
thing with rain shoe same thing with
those players like oh I just it kind of
just unfolds bias and what's been cool
with her too is to help facilitate that
growth and be able to create that
opportunity where she can make that big
impact right she's been traveling a lot
in the past year in the biz the past 18
months of submission she came out to
Japan she was running sets she went out
to China for a [ __ ] she's been playing
everywhere around the world and it's
been showing do people are taking notice
I'm telling you man proper opportunities
to keep this traffic right I mean she's
a great player so I'm happy that she
does get that opportunity but shoutouts
to our team
wherever you know each slave bang as
well right and then the other hat you
got you will still want to ELISA Chris
from Japan like Ali's be back in they
won the top elite show as well in Japan
so you know he knows checks that
bolton's players know the other chair
come very very well yeah especially in
Tokyo area there's at least three to
four really really strong ELISA players
that he has regular magic experience
with right so on both sides are gonna
know these characters interactions
pretty well
you know Concord does also have a few
other characters right she does have the
wing shout you know she doesn't she
don't she dabbles a little bit four
different characters you obviously one
character only I feel like lately cuddle
chorus wit me just primarily annalisa
player I don't think you ever gonna see
the links are you again I don't and I
actually don't disagree with that I
think that her her strongest character
has always been a release in her show
you just always been very very short but
one annalisa now and see the brief even
stop it snap back before funny right off
the bat in the knockout with that damage
right off the bat - 45 50 % hey the twg
finals are today I'm gonna be today like
right now playing all this means back
there it would restream the stream
on a slide in low no break now it'll be
the round oh thank God for at least
afaik out for the mission
give me them sour powers Brandon
y'all not killing my buzz and that's a
nasty robot he got jumped by a bunch of
robot man that was sick to talk about
early jump out bunch of robot
they call him the back right just jump
on keyword baby run the park
nice Johnny running everything the blog
cool wait you still in his position for
the wall she tried the OTG rocket board
should punish new stuff do it again hey
situation I see the sign honest man
cuddle for one game you know that
actually that blue the the race shark
shoulder might have been a mistake there
from you you get a save this rage by
just using the radiation shoulder and it
was built on the same same wall splat
same everything you know like they used
it eula too early they can't become a
statement because to do the shoulder and
to do the race drivers just holding the
button that's all it is you might have
just feel like I gotta hit this doesn't
matter what which one comes out
so I'm standing right behind right there
shadows shadows not even watching
camaraderie
rage
thanks for trying to bring this back
watch off with a cuddle for class to c3
oh that was a pain court wouldn't out
with the wheel yeah but her defense
really wanted that round
you like you know what I don't parts of
it
beautiful portal in the pickup yeah
great job guys it doesn't matter
come on sad point winner side against
yamasa you she is looking super
comfortable out there right now she was
up LCQ ash you've got way she's playing
right now
you on the other side it's very small
like that we'll use it at all oh yeah oh
you hold the hair out of his face you
brought that three straight yeah that
was very very close to looking shadow
band attention enough to give us some
advice I can take it
why she'd even think about it she went
straight face like look at schooi space
[Laughter]
that's shooting anytime you catch him in
the back i pizzelle [ __ ] look at like
a little kid in the candy store
i love the fact that he's sitting on the
seat back watching stream and every time
it comes back to him he's looking
exactly like yeah oh gee boy I saw
buzzing final game you're Martha you
were two equinoxes cuddle core yeah
wider state this time well clear-cut
walls as well
yeah
that's what happened at the beginning in
a second 8 right you finish the stream
right now oh what a life opportunity
we're gonna block to punish you honestly
I felt like you was playing with fire
that because he had rage Drive all you
have to do is do a drive and walk that
again way he's drawn it the block what a
weirdo broken this time for you to throw
and just come on leave momentum switch
now for you I've noticed today is that
his back turned I've been really what
they do
I mean sometimes not even a sustain
neutral job back turn to sweep for no
very first game lost that game and then
the second gave me the low and now you
see him carry on he's going down the
line yeah you brought back three rounds
the last games this time it's cuddle
corker can't you make it happen
she's got rage though momentum fight
that for you if we get the floater iron
fortress wanna be able to shut down the
drive yamasa you winner side moving on
running him back three Brown straight to
get control back at that set from cuddle
core oh man that was a that was really
really close but like you said that back
to her Mick someone started in the first
game and just went down the line with
the moves this is definitely tissue Mon
but here we go and this is definitely
some pies on those stuff right here
let's go tissue mom running this Raven
run it again shrim boo Saudi Arabia
Asya player and a really big impact uh
performance earlier this year when he
went to grand final against Arsenal
national really big it's turning out
there it's only ready oh yeah we get
that really six come back on futons 20
electric turnaround this mid-range
mix-up right now good Pope game from new
tip on early on good makes it just down
for once a units oh that's sweet chin
music to the wall up kids
back one spike I Sydnor since season 1
but still a good ender yeah there's the
damp with the downpours won the game hit
electric now true with the chance here
at the wall enrage sequence reads damage
throws Obama yeah rip why damage combo
yeah when you play Raven you only play
for that walk home yeah no no I mean
really it's so fun down back to zine
this time - sure - machine up right down
makes you canceling in The Guardian I'm
sure but to try to swing yeah you know
tradition one has been in the World
Finals pretty much every year this is
the first 22 years in a row he's worked
that's crazy to think about Ricky's ever
okay so many plays it's 7-under players
yeah World Finals top eight mainstays
fighting for their life and it looks
like it's kohai right as Liz Louise jr.
is that Daniel motto going up against
Erie this got to be winter side of this
yeah this is a I mean in this in this I
think Daniel motto I think most people
having things to be the one that kind of
which is properly pose the biggest
threat the hero peak be [ __ ] also in
this in this bracket but as well okay
right so then loser side yeah I think
most people would imagine a motto
that's the question there but how do the
ones that composure thought to here at
Daniel was definitely one of the ones
that I think like we said right the in
terms of Pakistani players that we were
looking at in this lzq you have to be in
you have to imagine the John a teeth and
hero I pick on at the tips of everyone's
tongue right when you go when you talk
about potential people who could not
only win this I'll see you put them
right that win need to tomorrow and then
do some huge damaging ingredient here I
was talking to GGC our yesterday and you
know we were talking about cuz he has
the first pick tomorrow yeah right and
in all honesty it's kind of the biggest
disadvantage he doesn't know who's gonna
mix things up on us yeah that's true but
but he does know those he's what he said
is that but he's like if anyone else I
might go to that man we all want to see
JD she ever played right well I mean it
does it what's that needs to happen here
tomorrow right well that's the scary
geez and the other threat with a lot of
those players to is as we saw at aa
crack up with the results right that are
unfortunately right right when I think
some people were questioning the results
with the koomer right taco cup comes up
top eight seven everybody's got a pocket
in everyone's around a pocket a cool and
here is no exception to that rule right
you got top eight at that tournament
what second-place finisher had to do by
mastery event as well but he does have a
pocket Akuma that's in the back this
Steve is the one that's how stealing the
show right now go man
you know a lot of super so there's no
nine out here and that's that whole
problem she interacted one of them was
to trade and look at the situation let
you can yamato's been using that for you
hurry likes really [ __ ]
I love Christ I like the animation his
hand is just up like oh crap looking
really good
hey maybe wall combos for babies for
pick it up down back to me two for the
finish gave them the Blues lovin that
night done by hero it's always so funny
to throw is like every time Steve has
rage we always he's gonna there's
nothing else you can do everybody does
[Music]
like it's the conversation you have with
yourself parties got raised drop he's
definitely going to use it why did I
just get your blocky but one milk F that
time frame you're not blocking any but
you said the key word there the timing
when you watch he reverses that need
that set that happened in just short of
a week ago in a lot of the situations
with rage Drive actually timing look in
yeah in a lot of situations where you
know your your red ranked us a friend
I'm just kidding right but that the
three Barnett plague I would have just
mastered right it's right there hero is
willing to say that he's meeting your
timing
and it's all about like this
split-second right like even if you
delay it like a little bit the best
instance is all it takes is killing and
another interaction that you saw come up
like a lot which kind of talks of even
more about hero strength in that regard
it's been locked down for two
interactions again page he went punch
parry so many time he had such a strong
beat on these timing he is very good at
being able to reach the opponent's
button press patterns often mix up right
there down back seat you or the rage dry
yo Ricky just rolled his eyes
can I tell you I definitely got here but
I got hit to left I believe eyes I'm mad
at myself
the serie fighting in your head all the
way up your face wait so you really
threaten to down back that he has the
mick support yeah you know that's one of
the one of the classics deep player
complete right it's like what do i do
against some of the turkey and here is
like this would you - up you make Jetray
and they get in their face you - up into
them and see what they're doing is if
they're coming forward then that's
perfect - that's what you want right
today right then be counted
I haven't seen that's it hero to zero
over Daniel motto clothes were set but
most cook clothes first game right but
the matches covergirl away guys are
getting ridiculous it's ridiculous
oh yeah let's go reading words yes huge
and boy person run it black West Coast
Japan versus West Coast USA let's go
you too boy beats all of us though right
well I imagine like there's just a bunch
of Japanese guys they're all just yo
they're all like we are lead but what
Japanese kids play that's been really
good lately AHA today metal yeah he's
ready Tokyo he's been killing it out
there - he's also your point though he
is so sick we're talking early he was
like yeah I read a plaque at the new P
wait he's here because speak he gave up
his butt alight spot but like beer
league and enjoy period couldn't make it
so then he went to the running back with
the third place finisher so it wasn't
eSports ecosystem there I never was that
good at crypto man I still got a little
bit of money in my pocket let's go save
shames looking further down to the ocean
boy back to the hall rage that's gonna
be big
I'm still like that's a lot of damage
[Applause]
what to have to watch all that just to
get you ads in the face that is so so
nice because I'm too big up the power
question window is so large
yeah then when you talk about other
characters when they talk about this
matchup to like that was something that
Jotaro talked a lot about recently he
doesn't like playing knock this against
geeks ironically that's because of the
power crush problem it's really easy for
him to just kind of know laughs I love
those two I was like you
let me make sense that's probably one of
the biggest is uh less tools and a lot
of magic so far this round good mixer
just jabs down for ones then while
standing ones as well oh boy common
situation set point for Yugi boy still
damned for to begin my big damage I mean
that there's no damage karriesue but he
got knocked off
oh shut down the drive
alright back to pick up a hop kick
attempt no go Jochen boy to 0 over run
it black USA oh good don't get oh my god
okay so two different players rightful
we saw
this year versus that's not go well at
all parade because it looked like a cave
he wanted you know he wants to play his
style but knowing every time he did that
Ibiza she was getting hell yeah wait I
can't do this anymore
yeah and it looked like that was just
kind of the way where he just played so
well and yeah but now dojin those
different different player and a
different character and also yeah
because of laura's right he has a lot of
built-in movement into his moveset as
well gonna be much easier to chase down
so she wants to be able to turn a bait
to get away from Pete story saw a
trinket some health background that last
night we just saw actually between game
boy and run a black with winners finals
so we're gonna see Jojo boy top throw on
the winners side and it also ripped
camera so bad and he's still got some
some common get up
[Music]
[Laughter]
Yoshimitsu banjo start playing in the
middle of the final round
I always have to be aware oh well this
sounds like you pay by night musician
jouji comes right back and then once
your don't use really good these five
around clothing about real fast I'm
telling you man he really just dislike
the song here's the one interesting
thing about ideas that I like he always
goes to infinity he does not play walled
stages interested because Yoshi is so
good at the walls at the tech traps
cetera yeah but I think that even better
no stages were tell you right now I
musician is literally getting life back
in these situations and Obama he was
talking about if you see spin around and
going to like meditation stance like
damn now I got it forces the opponent to
have to make a decision dead man's yeah
the best part is when they do at the
beginning in the round like you want to
change like why even JC's not even
getting help and but he force you to
walk the wallpapers the character play
then because of the way he plays his
style as on impetus deeper section we
remember
Wow that's dirty dirty God oh why does
that work
that's the back this penis we saw the
whip our class tell us was like why
don't I ever low-fare you always seem to
come to his block it again
[Music]
not having anyone though now what check
solid option I'm magician IV this baby
he's doing magic as far as I'm concerned
your magician the I say magician I've
definitely caught him I'm using a
magician in real life right now don't
you looking like a bound believer right
now though man dude nice punish he's
dead he's dead oh shut up
there's damage scale reduction right
it's no matter what I say he dead he was
dead I meant to free the players I
didn't know why don't you do some good
call
don't you hear swam Wow nice job there
you go all right great job don't you
just getting on the final round and beat
it pretty good their eyes it up don't
want a piece that solid dolls
we haven't heard that song for more than
two rounds
musician yet in that game CAK waiting in
the wings in the back thank oh let me
see the - he still has support mm-hmm
I'm right there another one of the
organizers from a rev major as well
geometric plane here back to the walls
relatively large states though so plenty
of room from I'm musician around there
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
how close and how doujins around there
great timing on that logo right here eck
ignite musician Michael lo Perry there
took his time I got a blow mix up and
the pound beautiful round three don't
you set boy fight against I'm musician
now indulge in whatever the halls
whenever we get this song don't leave
one more round
so that means told you once a we're
about to find out walls yeah I think
we're in if your hex and real big guy
Ricky where it was this song let me make
the hole whiskey let me make the cut oh
my god oh man yo just give me the come
back to fighting to use me I've heard
those make sure you have placed a ton of
the word still got questions I'm a
fighter oh we get multiple rounds you I
musician still in it how many loves a
song I think I love this this is my gym
that combo got a final final around here
dojin versus I'd musician winners final
big game here Grantham oh we just did a
jab stop it sure you wanna do something
quick just hit him Wow gorgeous
sanfur shone the flash take him to the
wall that was soldier
be careful yeah yeah you can't take it
the wall that should be used to Scott
uh-huh done a beautiful job never mind
musician making that come back you can
see the crowd behind am I even from this
angle you can see all the players like
sitting up and watching the mainstream
matches so this is really really cool we
got some matches here this is John
written below this is also winners
finals as well but John ting up one game
the Eddy mad Julia Julia someone we
didn't see that wasn't a real match how
unreal how it we dreamed it okay like
like it's like the ending the Daleks all
dreams ology
so we're talking about daunting Swift
punching what Eddie is so sharp he's
really good at fading you to sleep yeah
in those big launch especially like
range to range 3 he's all he's all if
feels like he's always waiting for it
well that's a good mix up off of it
buttocks like the back three well these
guys to just avoid each other nice
pickup different yeah and finally get
here
look this reward here just clean carry
across the stage sick oh my god threw
down for two I'm gonna do all this crazy
stuff like yeah I'm gonna stop
[Music]
folks slowly starting to add up here
Gabby Dundee has the lead now because of
these folks but now mold will finally
get me to pick up the wall option
mix-ups as well nice County and the
slaps go go
time winding down here bold bold with
rage and the blue stuff ready to go pick
it up though stars are still active that
was a tiny picture if I was playing I'm
freaking out right now
and step point John think trying to
punch us to get the winter side top 30
to fifth place last year finally
flipping around just pick you back up
what did you say guys Johnson to John
roll button down for to the elbow he
called down for two just almost died
this time the right bunch of bull gold
nice block and John thinking to be the
one moving on with his side let's go the
jump B John gets home he's from the
Philippines but he put talking into
losers Wow yeah
here today yes sir okay originally
looking at this point I think most
people would have expected talking to be
the one going up against the John winner
side interesting bit of an upset but
that means talking and lose your side
that's your up that's a dangerous shark
swimming down there man yeah we've
talked about the pigs I forgot about
talking right these are this two
it's kind of quite talkies had a very
down year this year but yeah I remember
day that one tournament where you did
amazing at wow look at the dam is why
why you know why that's a big he was
carrying a car - I love it the thing
about the Johnsons is style right yeah
you see that you seem to emphasize a lot
of nice slicer and a lot of honor whilst
anyone into the blade will to follow up
the new range as well playing around the
jab range for something command throws I
was looking for two as well but the big
thing is when he ends a lot of
complicated even really end a lot of
combos in the side switching command
graph he emphasizes a lot of attack
incentives and pressure at the wall
on pareo below 40 frames I'm pretty sure
that was a massage just that little late
thing at the end of sending players from
regions that don't in sending them out
to events the John being a product of it
yeah shout out to you I um talk work up
obviously but then there's also a son
ship also benefactor of that peacekeeper
dojo for that one yo Sean also you are
you'd have been doing a lot of work when
it comes to getting eyes on a lot of
these not even peeling back that round
one
let's go Craig Creek beat is an infinite
space inside
jam the ribs break the loop I'm get one
score per carry and then force
lithography that's what I was talking
about use the power crush out of it why
is one of the heavy favorites you're at
the LCQ yeah this top 16 theta whatever
is gonna be ridiculous it's top 32 bait
I'll tell you what I'm going up I love
rustic throw when I love that gladiator
movie I'm ready to be entertainment top
32 is gonna be crazy
we're throwing no telephones either
[Laughter]
begin to spread Oh dirty get off
who did the tackle setup well you can
just run on the top attack yeah same
thing
[Laughter]
whoa nice ball back oh we tried the crab
pump up on get some start here okay Don
and rate there's Papa won't be enough
damage all right well is it out nice
that's all you need one bubble give that
one bubble then just probably still
alive
yeah you get one you can get three
exactly the other guys get to be first
oh yeah got plenty of time we're going
around the world first he's that way in
earth type
regarding get toys hop on the OL the low
against the power crush help avenge oh
my goodness what a hit this is
terrifying go yo he got it back there
these wooden buttons out there that's
making the John stay calm we final round
game to hop on know what
nice attempt does it find it though
strive God here we go you saw the fear
coming in his eyes like oh no this out
of teeth but hey oh this is final game
two winners final of this pool
alright tied up now this is this would
be a huge upset if this goes down this
way yes and this is one is she messed up
now for 2000 a huge mistake and this is
something we were talking about earlier
too right season three can't get so
again a buff to his janab right very
very big hit box on that you see the
utilizing a lot against Akuma right push
them around or you know oh god he might
be dead
the wall wasn't super close the beach
jiggle a hop kick here comes the combo
look at the wall oh he was right
I mean he's had so many opportunities to
close out matches but he does just
something something different with like
pressure man you know he knows the
moments so big yeah I mean that wall
splat he had he could have just done the
regular wall combo be tried to go for
max damn right but the character was not
on the wall anymore I mean that was a
good like oh the fact that he was aware
enough to change up their combo like I
was thinking the same thing like as the
King platter like alright what are you
gonna do now in this situation but not
too bad but bait your shoutouts to Kwan
before holding it down all year
especially sponsoring the Tekken World
Tour you see they have that cyber sail
still going oh wow it's long yeah the
obsidian as well as the drone I got one
of those myself shoutouts the Kwan my
head on over to a qualm bow usa.com
yeah it's that combo ages Plus obsidian
for that price that's great yeah it's a
ridiculous deal that's pretty cool
does it come with the bows on them too
yes I talk to 725 it comes with the
bowls if it does not hold you're going
to take a quick break has been godlike
so far there's still more to come join
us right after this